rivers run deep with history
epic tales of the landscapes and
societies that neighbor their shores
not to mention their own winding
heritage
these old channels are paths the
mississippi river has taken in the past
at one time its waters even flowed into
the atchafalaya river
for decades the mississippi river has
tried to carve its way back to the
achafalaya river
practically bursting at the seams
through what's called an avulsion
a river of vulces or breaks its banks
when sediment chokes up its channel
and reduces its carrying capacity enough
that the water is forced to find a more
efficient path
the u.s army corps of engineers has kept
the river in check
using a combination of floodgates and
levees called the old river control
system
human engineering might have brought
this river to heel but it requires
constant vigilance and not all rivers
are so compliant
in 2008 levees on the kosi river
ruptured the flood swept across india
and took more than 400 lives
while displacing another three million
in the aftermath of the flood the indian
government built even more levees
river scientists now say that higher
levees may actually do more harm than
good
that's because they constrain a river
and force it to dump
sediment within its channel raising its
riverbed and reducing the amount of
water it can safely carry
using models and laboratory tools called
stream tables
researchers are getting better at
understanding when and where
an avulsion might occur there are two
key hot spots
the first is at the foot of the
mountains where rivers slow
down models show that in this region
the slowing rivers tend to drop
sediments and silt up their channels
leading to an avulsion but what about
river deltas
where slope isn't a factor here
the interaction between river flow and
ocean tides determines where the river
is likely to evolve
flooding in the lower parts of the delta
washes away sediment
setting the table for avulsions upstream
at the head of the delta
scientists modeling the mississippi
river have found that its natural
avulsion point would be right near the
old river control
while promising these models can account
for human effects
like deforestation upstream which adds
silt to the river
or climate change which is raising sea
levels
and structures like levees and gates
will only age and
fail with time making long-term
solutions critical
along china's yellow river engineers are
pursuing soil conservation projects
and ways to flush out sediment deposits
better predictions could lead to better
solutions perhaps grounded in lessons
we've learned
from the complex history that links
rivers and people
[Music]
you